well Brennan it's Wednesday we're back
we're back and I want to thank you for
promoting my never grow up and well we
sold 1 million copies 1 million you know
what's weird is it's not Hulu it's not a
Hulu till December and I got so much
[ __ ] for that it's not Hulu ever like
bro you guys released this two years ago
I never said it's an English now this is
the yeah this is the visual audio if
we've edited it out we've we've sweep
with what's called we spice it up a
little bit we should have called it the
mishandled one our spice it up a little
bit it's it's called it dogs don't
really suspect like this one out well or
we should have called it yeah well I and
I took a hand I took a flat hand to all
the people involved
my agents everybody else and I slapped
him about the face ears and buttocks so
it's not can they do not much people
find it have you ever been slapped by a
girl in the face uh god not really no I
have [ __ ] hurts
I've been slapped super hard in my
[ __ ] face really uh-huh it stings
hey it's [ __ ] yes sting it hurts
yes I've been slapped on Instagram
before Twitter where people drop some
knowledge on like oh yeah yeah yeah do
you saw how about last night I was
talking on my show how you know I went
people always post like pray for Vegas
pray for New Orleans pray for Paris pray
for Symphony know pray for Sandy Hook
all that I'm like you're not doing
anything you're actually not doing
anything when you post that stuff you
know it's religious I mean it's a I do
think that there's something comforting
to people who suffered that people are
praying and thinking about you I get it
beep but it's actually not doing much
like you're not you're not helping the
situation like maybe if your religions
you say the prayers are helping I'm
saying you're physically not doing
anything so maybe can donate blood
there's things you can actually do to
make a difference if you if you're there
you have them you know I'm saying like
you posting there's that saying it's
awesome stuff
thing to do yeah celebrities do it you
don't quite buy it yes and I am still
good because I was getting shipped
because people are like you never post
those things they pray for Vegas
so then yesterday I was like no I'm
gonna do a go fund like I'll donate
money to GoFundMe it's the thing to do
sure here's they need to meet a
requirement of 10 million yeah you're a
Tory I think it gives 10 you gave a
grant I gave a grant yeah it's I mean
it's you know it's a lot of money that's
um it's better than nothing dude I
posted that trying to hope in hope to
inspire people also do the same yeah
I've never seen so much hate why I'm any
post FY baffles me um yeah I think that
no way I think pray like like so so
sometimes things are without explanation
or they bring you to your knees right
sometimes all you can do is pray because
the world is so [ __ ] up right so so
like I remember when the towers were
coming down never forget it I was on the
phone with patty Jenkins and the second
tower came down and I was I was I looked
down on my hands I'm not a religious
person but my hands were in a prayer
position cuz that's all I could do like
I I found myself grasped in my hands and
you know I thought to myself this is
very interesting that I'm kind of like
you yeah you know so that there is that
there is that feeling but I I definitely
think that you make a point which is
that there are a lot of people that say
that like when Muhammad Ali died and all
these people never watched boxing or
anything they posted the great Muhammad
Ali I'm like listen man it could become
these trend it becomes a meme arrived
here yes writes all these trends like
like JJ Watt when there's the huge
disaster in Houston with uh with the
hurricane he didn't post pray for
Houston he put let's raise money to make
a difference yeah yeah but there's like
this this following this this sheep-like
culture will just post easily you feel
like you have to do something that yeah
I know you're saying yeah but very
strange that Pope don't like that mmm
why I don't know in that strain you got
in trouble you got you got [ __ ] for
giving money I mean that's really weird
to me man anyway it's a very interesting
and we're going to get into what part
I'm part of my drop in Al's and we can
get in
before that is how sensitive people are
just you can't even talk about guns do
you know you can it's it's so religious
that you know when you when you even
bring up the idea that there could be a
discussion around weapons of war that
can kill lots of people
like so so so so the argument for a lot
of people is like it's not the gun it's
it's not it's not the kind of person
behind yeah they say we don't have this
kind of number one argument is we don't
have a gun problem we have a mental
health problem well okay but then what
are you okay so the art but but but the
problem with that also is to help this
guy didn't show any signs of mental
health issues but mental health is
everywhere issues are all over the very
heart then when they don't have guns you
don't you're not seen the same well well
having said that though I understand the
gun rights people because the thing is
that in the Bastille Day Parade in Nice
I think it was where the guy drove a
truck into you know and killed Oh 86
people and injured I don't know how many
so the real question is this we know you
need a class-3 license for certain
weaponry especially fully automatic
weapons it's called a class or license
it takes a while to get there's a whole
situation you have to do most people
obviously who own machine guns most
people who own guns are law-abiding
citizens and not out there spree
shooting the question and you can't even
have this you can't even raise this
question we're gonna get [ __ ] just for
talking I didn't want to talk about this
yeah it's bad so it's fascinating
because because it speaks to a larger
thing that it's fun to examine but if
you were to say we know that we know
that most people would not allow anybody
to go in a store and buy a
shoulder-launched a Stinger missile
that's an explosive device so gun people
make a big difference big distinction
and they should but let's just say a
belt-fed 50 caliber machine gun which
you can bother also saying yeah which is
which is you know goes through you know
you can have a car door I'm gonna save
you an engine block and save you today
and can do can wreak crazy havoc yeah
you know I think most people
say okay you can't just go inwards and
your driver's license and walk out with
it even though some Second Amendment
guys are like everything should be
illegal but I think most people you can
actually have a discussion on we should
probably have at least a license you
have to go through you know like kind of
like a training before you get it the
way you do with a car or something but
even bringing that up even bringing up
like where are the limits of a weapon
war that that already becomes so
contentious and fascinating to me
because guns and I'm a gun owner but
guns tend to be so emotional for people
Americans it cuts to the fabric and the
core of who we feel like we are it's
almost like when you tell guys that
there's going to be some kind of some
kind of limitation on the kind of gun
you can just buy right away at a gun
show you're cutting their dick off it's
a very interesting emotional this role
yeah and you know well at the same time
Republican or but gun rights activists
are right when you say well we need to
legislate more well look the guy who did
this terrible thing in in Vegas was very
did everything in the legal way bought
his guns legally had went to background
or you know everything got corrected
though you know how you said those guns
are very expensive some of them are too
so the way he made it automatic it's a
it's a bump it's a buck what's a twenty
dollar add-on they can do for all those
guns to make up it's a little more than
that so I so so yes so you can buy a
good ar-15 maybe for two grand fifteen
hundred dollars sometimes three grand
depending you can modify them my buddies
got a shop where he does this then
there's the bump stock I guess which is
I think you can you it's I think from
what I've heard I talked to people who
actually one guy who has one we actually
had an expert in email us okay who sells
them and actually did went over the
rights and you can push it forward and
how it's it's literally add this little
device money bus $19.99 to do on them to
do a bike it's not this he goes that
when people bring up pricing issues it's
not oh thank God you saved us it just
got too deep races on it just got a lot
better looking at all their to me race
okay that were oh you what we doing were
you boxing frank grillo
frank grillo who's the star look at the
way he moves
what's up brother long time no see man I
thought those are two knee braces like
let me give you H GHS let me give you uh
let me give you a little per curse or on
what mr. grill has been doing he sold
the show to Netflix where he goes to
different parts of the world and again
immerses himself in the fight culture
Mexico he was with Juan Marquez and I
was with uh I was with nacho Beristain
that was a great natural bursting
amazing Julio Cesar Chavez Chiquita
Gonzales I was close to the mic I was
with so many of the great legends of
Mexican boxing I was in Tepito Mexico
which is probably the most dangerous
place in the world where there is a gym
where where Oscar De La Hoya trained
Jorge Vera runs this amazing gym for a
lot of underprivileged kids in that in
that area and what do you go in there
and do friend I go in I train I train
with the with the coaches I change the
coaches but more importantly I kind of
learn about the culture and how
important fighting is to the culture
love through the eyes of the fighters
the trainers and and I you know it's
amazing what what the sports the sport
of boxing or MMA what it does for the
communities well you just got back from
the from Brazil I was in Positano yeah I
was a Josette although at their home
Jose Jose Jose Jose and I was I was with
day-day who trains him who's got a
famous gym down there there's probably
30 guys sparring with four ounce gloves
and no headgear that's how they're bad I
mean I go them are badass I was with I
was paralyzed oh I was with Pedro Rizzo
and his gym he's got an amazing thing
he's backed by the oil company that
gives him probably six or seven
buildings he trains champions he trains
all the kids from the favelas he does
tutoring in math and in Incan and
English and then he has a program for
psychology with a psychologist so that
these kids from the favelas can deal
with the issues that are so amazing I
was with marlin Sandra who does a very
similar thing in the
the Santa almost did you go to the
favelas was up in the favelas they his
gym is called the hill of Champions it's
a little tiny room
how cool are the favelas well I mean ops
you see a lot of poverty but it's just
the the kind of the love and the
atmosphere that was good for me from
from because you both have been there
for me from the media
I think of drug gangs that run
neighborhood you know what it is though
it's 99% hard-working people right who
are you know at the poverty level but
they work they do incredibly
hard-working people and they want what
we want for our kids which is education
which is a better life and these
fighters these fighters like pedro rizzo
like long you know evening I was with
Bustamante he's doing this a similar
thing they all have social programs
where they take these kids from the
fellows and give back because they know
how tough it is man all those guys know
exactly didn't Joe say Aldo come from
the pain he comes from well yeah he
comes from who up begins with an H he
comes from a part of Brazil that is just
beyond poverty a lot of those favelas
are but it's not that it's like like
it's not like war as or cartel like they
they have their drug you know rings
there yeah but but they it's almost they
police the area like the no one's in
danger nobody's in danger if you're from
another favela and you go there to get
drugs or and Dean okay you're not in
danger okay and I was good I don't know
if this was if they when you went there
Frank but like we went there and I saw
kids training doing jiu-jitsu yep might
I might I speak more times okay great
yeah nice but I saw him doing it on dirt
on Derek what it with no gear I'm like
what the [ __ ]
so we I came back with all this gear
that's what we're doing and we were say
I would there like that you're good I'm
like I don't have anything we're about
like you don't need all this security
provided all the security like you don't
need this man now in fact when I went
Marlin Sandra who's amazing he trains
with Joseon he has this gym and they
said to me look you he's going to give
you five minutes and you can ask him
some questions but it's probably gonna
be very formal with him and and I wind
up going up there his kids got a Captain
America shirt on his kid freaks out I
because he sees I'm hugging his kid as
if
was Mike talking to his kid me and him
become quick friends we walked through
every inch of the favela for about two
and a half hours then we went back later
with the cameras to get you and Josie
not me and my me and my team okay
him and me him and Jose ever in the gym
training at Davis gym gym he went with
the coach
yeah but I got an insight to the favelas
in a way that you know we walked through
the Bellas and he's a hero there so and
if I'm with him I'm cool so no son did
you eat the food he ate the food bro
drinking beers on the unsighted the shot
is open what I'm so jealous what it's I
feel like when I was in Indonesia
we're with these Dayak the original
indigenous people and I just got on the
back of a moped with this dude and he
took me into where they live in
Indonesia and you don't and I ate that
food that they're they're cooking out of
a big barrel you know I mean and as you
can that experience that the smell and
the taste and that shooting no I just
those two no I I went to Thailand where
where I experienced lady would when you
talk you have lady boys who fought and
won but I experienced yep
I experienced poverty in Thailand and
Myanmar which you know the British to
Burma it's amazing what the Europeans
had done to the world but the British
came and Burma and and then left and but
I was in the countryside in in Myanmar
where these kids have nothing I mean
they don't have enough food to get
through the day like homeless or almost
homeless they live in a little shack
where they train and they kick banana
trees I mean it's amazing heartbreak I
don't know it's heartbreaking but then
there's something Noble I'm not there
there's sense of community they're kids
they also don't know any better right I
don't know that's life they don't know
any better and they're amazing they're
studs and they're happy yeah and then I
you know look I go to Thailand and I'm
with bull cow one of the greatest Muay
Thai fighters right spent the day with
him trained with him Jesus right but
then went into the countryside in
Thailand and it's the same through-line
you know the level of poverty and and
what fighting is for these people you
know that represent a sport its life its
life its life and that's what the
show that's kind of the through lines I
got one more stop we're going to Israel
next week on a Tel Aviv damn deal with
the Seychelles dude in Africa
yeah man with those giant black eyes and
a gun bring up bring up the Senegalese
wrestlers yeah yeah yeah and I met two
of the greatest of all time you can pop
them up its name lock dumare and moto
loo you're good and spell that chin yeah
you can just bright Lamba it's la I
think it's la amb is that is the proper
camera yep there it is yeah they're like
how they do shades X go down to the
second one
okay that's best guys okay so see this
guy to toe warren sapp like how big was
he
oh dude being that Warren Sapp really
yeah and moves like he's 510 and they
train like they'd now they know how to
train they train like MMA it's wrestling
what is what it is it's it's doing
videos at their knuckle it's bear night
it's done in the sand
it's bare-knuckle boxing it goes on for
an hour
it's bare-knuckle boxing and then it
goes into Greco and they are advanced
video furniture and then if you get
three points down it's over so you never
Groppo on the ground so much because as
soon as three points touch it's it's
done so it's box
it's bare-knuckle boxing and kind of
Greco freestyles combined almost like
Samba where it touches the ground
there's no submissions no whoever gets
thrown right yeah that's the but look
but you can advance and if I Greco with
boxing oh oh this [ __ ] these are not
even big guys
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way Senegal the most tolerant
place you ever want to go these are 95%
Muslim people they voted for a Catholic
president they intermarried there is no
they don't there's no snow radical you
know Islam [ __ ] if these are
beautiful that's what Muslim its what
the Muslim religion really is did you do
you feel in danger at all and never are
you serious never man I am never ending
I never and I'm in danger
I'm Ito Mexico is what is Marjolein
cartel and you have you heard about
though I don't mean right here about the
show runner on narco yes not the show
runner I know that don't you okay she
got murdered by the cartel exact outing
for sale I saw my guy was you're in
you're in cartel in like what the raki
is everywhere
yeah so I'm a guy like four weeks ago my
yeah yeah a hoary there who runs the gym
in Tepito his son he was my fixer right
and we would walk through the markets a
Tepito
I went to where Santa morta
you know which is the the saint of the
misbegotten yeah where this woman runs
the church there which is you no one
goes near there white boy doesn't go
near there right oh yeah by the end of
it we he was almost his brother was
murdered his father had to deal with
that but we got so connected with all
these people I get so connected by the
end of it he puts his arm around me and
some camera and he says what you want in
Tepito I want in Tepito what goes wrong
for you in Tepito goes wrong for me in
Tepito in other words saying you're my
brother
yeah you could whenever you need here
good you're good yeah yeah and that was
the they told me Jose Aldo wouldn't talk
to me
we sat for an hour who the hell does a
great guy I just put his head in my at
the end was like a great guy you know
his burger joint yes good burgers yeah
man but since Al is a great guys a great
guy
yeah so you don't get to their levels
all these guys are speaking you don't
get to to exactly what they're doing in
life being an ass [ __ ] Joe's a Alton
and by the way what they give back in
their in their collective community
is I've never seen anything like it and
that's from fighting from the
Brotherhood and sisterhood of fighting
comes you know all of this philanthropic
stuff that without it in those
communities there'd be a lot of trouble
there a hundred or so a lot of those
kids yeah and it's a shame because in
America you know we have our problems
here you know in New York even LA a lot
of these youth box and programs you can
take an away get their money's riding
that's right there's a lot d+ gödel
aside from Pedro Rizzo who gets funding
from the from the oil company which is
really amazing a lot of these guys are
doing it you know they're kind of from
hand to mouth you know they're kind of
figuring out about do it for fame
they're not doing it to buy a big house
in honor of the real visionary I stay
where they they stay in the favelas
they're not looking to leave it's not
you know it's to take the cold showers
and build man it's just I love my son's
name is Rio like I was really a funny
but the first time I went to Rio but to
this time this thing which which started
out as hey maybe I got something cool
here has entirely changed my life a good
high early change and that's so cool man
yeah that's so cool yeah well now you're
off to Israel after this I'm going to
New York for wheelman this week to do
some talk shows and commonweal man will
man by the way this show this movie you
did in Netflix is getting crazy with oh
yeah I know I'm crazy I've been reading
the reviews you have like it doesn't get
better it doesn't real man oh my god
it's a great it's a great moment we're
proud of it and I mix it up frankly I'm
not just say cuz you're here I love it
was really funny thing that I Chuck
y'all fit in anything does too and then
like when I was at perch - I was in the
theater I felt good well do we oh man is
that graph seen it twice it's [ __ ]
great it's fun and and you popped up on
Captain America Mall yeah
yeah well he's in the biggest movie I
think one of the biggest action films of
all time
oh the chain Warrior you're basically
Brad Pitt and Chyna
what can you explain the [ __ ] like first
of all you spoke English the whole time
you're in China how dare you take a
Chinese man job I'll take it again take
it again
yeah the movies made nine hundred
million dollars nine hundred million
dollars rolling in China that's the
first one okay oh you're in the second
one can we get a trailer you in this yes
a little little bit but look at it right
there right they [ __ ] with it they
made my eyes deep you know what our but
you know [ __ ] you know what's his name
Ben Affleck and what's his boy's name
Matt Damon Matt Damon tried doing you
know the Great Wall try and change like
yeah I got a clothing line now coming
out in China
I sell sunglasses The Blob jacket Bob
Sapp dude you shade you shave your head
you're going right back to [ __ ] TV so
keep that [ __ ] hair and by the way is
there a trailer that I can see on this
cuz I would just I would yeah there
Frank no no no you don't feel it the
people are cool but you know it's kind
of towns I mean is China dude what about
the food it's terrible it's terrible
mmm you got to do what you got to do
those better Chinese food in New York I
got bad I've got some fans done movies
enjoy shit's on Dave you just [ __ ]
all over man like [ __ ]
everywhere man want some crazy [ __ ]
anything oh [ __ ]
Hey look at this
this guy's this guy finance the movie
himself basically right 25 million bucks
it's gonna make a billion dollars oh
[ __ ] losing
so the Russo brothers produced it you
know they do the Captain America movies
well that's bull king he's now the most
famous kind of thing it's actually
that's kind of cool he's just killed it
that guy in China just must be exhausted
Mario like you this a lot of guns by the
way right yeah this is you guys had some
serious yeah we had a good fight Frank
Frank you don't play around when you got
a gun cocked up like that
jump over that tank dude what up who's
that guy it's a big boy who's the
wrestler there we W gun Frank you know
your way around us off I'd like you to
call me Big Daddy when we're watching no
dude I'm gonna call him Big Daddy
no no mr. international mr.
international all right so so CIA calls
meeting at you and they go listen you
realize that you're the biggest American
actor now in China you gotta be kidding
me come on what about Matt Damon Tom
Cruise head time cuz he like Tom Cruise
I'll let your goddamn throat he's a he's
relentless ya know what don't let that
message you Tom you think you're bad
okay cruise go do what Scientology Oh
tom well you know when when he did
Vampire Diaries with Brad Pitt Brad Pitt
chat about him interview with the
vampire
yeah that's here retirees are e when he
did fifty shades of red here for the
vampire movie alright you're so right
that was if the interview with vampire
and there was a there was a real rivalry
I guess and Brad Pitt was like it was
just unfortunate he was getting
competitive with me and I was like well
I mean come on dude yeah Roos right good
yes Brad Pitt Brad Pitt does [ __ ]
hey a Frank how let's just ballpark how
many more big movies internationally can
do before you go full-blown [ __ ]
Johnny Depp Nicolas Cage crazy and you
come in here just with like an old skull
how you got from Africa and you're
talking about safari sorry Ellen here
are do one White Rhino and they'll be
getting great I mean crazy reviews like
you know we're crazy comparisons you
know it's really funny and and and but
the funniest one is and and it's like it
goes on and on and wax Inco attic about
you know I am Charles Bronson and this
and then it says and then it says as a
second-tier movie story
a level performance in b-level movies by
bill by the way you and I take at the
wheel man I swear to God when I tackle
you uses prove that you're a movie star
second here
well I'm biased so I don't think so but
building your first layer but but first
here there's like four people here
here's the difference between old on I'm
gonna give you these
I'm you better watch it no [ __ ]
you're about Tom Cruise and I'm gonna
tell you what the dose by the way both I
love you work with Tom Cruise for long I
love Tom do then watch me let me let me
give you can I tell you the difference
can is rank Grillo Frank Roller here's
the funnel Bradley Cooper Tom Cruise
these guys who love acting they love
acting they love the details they love
it all he likes hanging and drinking
wine and enacting issues a guy's day
listen there's one place where the truth
is constant and that is in a boxing gym
a wrestling mat an MMA cage truth when
you're singing truth dancing and when
your head truth is constant right so
when you're an actor it's like it's a
fake world fake everything's fake it's
all an illusion and it's it's fun it's
fun it's fun the way riding a moped is
fun oh yeah yeah I you know whatever I
meant but if I wasn't doing
action-oriented films I would be bored
out of my mind if I wasn't you're not
gonna do like if that's you do Lincoln
Lincoln as a racecar driver no I'm not
doing lady I don't give a [ __ ] about me
yeah he's a racist yeah so so now yeah
did you watch any fights with those guys
out there like yeah I went to the fights
we went to the fights their gym day days
gym they have this shoot promotion and
we went and watched the fight in fact
shoot us some tough guys yeah them throw
today yeah
josée Aldo's protege [ __ ] names
slipping my he fought and destroyed but
he comes from where Josie Aldo comes
from and that's his hero and he's
following in the footsteps they're
having a problem with guys from favelas
getting being able to come here and
fight because they don't have birth
certificates they don't have been at
Slover Tech sheriff he was you know
undefeated for a long time he was like
kind of this boogeyman Brazil and it
took I mean four years for him to get
over and fight yeah it was the big hole
they don't they don't they don't have
paperwork you know they just don't have
paper they don't have paperwork there's
no records of them you know are a lot of
them surfers I know hints of Gracie's
yeah yeah a lot of him is raising money
by the way hens are Gracie so I was with
this is crazy
we'll go to art they who had a famous
fight with Hicks and Gracie at Pepe
Beach in 1988 which kind of was which is
which is kind of the jump off point
between where Brazilian jiu-jitsu became
kind of started to become famous outside
of Brazil was a famous video you go to
arte fought luta livre right and it was
at the time where where Ludo was you
know noogie because it was for the kids
in the favelas and I meet with who go to
art they we wind up grappling a bit in
the spot that him and Hickson had the
fight there that's cool he gave me the
whole rundown on what it was about and
then later five days later he went to
hoechlin well then I went and I hung out
with Hoke ler Gracie at Hoecker Gracie
at his Academy where they had a second
fight and Hickson won again and then
everybody kind of came together and the
rest was history so cool then i sat with
Hobson Gracie at the beach for an hour
and a half who is Carlos Gracie son
hélio Gracie's nephew to talk about the
the the origin of the family from
Scotland Brazil I learned that they
identify with their Scottish roots as
much as they do with their Brazilian
roots did they did anyone touch on like
the state of jiu-jitsu now how it's like
kind of a business here in a man it is
absolutely a business but it was is this
from the beginning you know the Gracie
family they were well-to-do from the
very beginning they were trial
there were diplomats and they had an eye
on business Carlos Gracie had an eye on
business from the very beginning about
getting this that's why they would
that's why they did Valley to dos that's
why they started these things to get
people to see and to prove and to prove
how superior Brazilian jiu-jitsu gracie
jiu-jitsu was well i mean if there's a
dynasty like this a family that has this
kind of gravitas in any other an
influence I challenge you to give me
their name because I think as far as a
family's concerned and what the family
are saying right I mean what other
family kind of has has well couldn't you
say that the Gracie's in a way were the
harbinger and the catalyst to MMA
weren't they the beginning Bali - no it
was the auroria no it's as far as the
UFC sure yeah or just am what we know is
MMA the idea of Ali - though and a lot
of people would argue Bruce Lee was kind
of the first yeah you can argue using a
real fighters no no but he was kind of
the first to mix the martial arts
open to it because a lot of people back
in martial arts ago well if I do
Taekwondo karate bullsh if I do karate
jujitsu [ __ ] and Bruce Lee removal
chill we can mix it all together and
then you might have a complete my only
caveat to that is that he didn't fight
in rings that doesn't matter he we had
such an impact in such an employment
rate celebrity big so that's also the
one who brought up that type of business
- American yeah yeah when before guys
just trying to figure era yeah but you
know I think the original valley tutos
were true mixed martial arts competition
in the sense that each discipline was
represented and at the end it was which
discipline was the best or was the most
powerful and that was kind of what mixed
martial arts tournaments were and now
mixed martial arts has become its own
discipline 100% where everybody trains
kind of the same way you know it's you
need to know everything you have a
wrestling coach of a boxing coach you
have a jiu-jitsu coach you know you um I
have to tell you but so now it's
homogenized and it's become one thing
zone sport its own sport yeah yeah you
know but if I feel it's so
I would [ __ ] I'm sure you're gonna do
this it'd be such an instant debate cuz
if you go to Japan with Japanese
jiu-jitsu right they're gonna go whoa
hold up
yeah we had the first yeah right mixed
martial arts and your exact got this guy
that's exactly then if you go to Russia
they're gonna move up yeah with some but
we were doing this that's right then you
know you move around people that
everyone else don't story the Turks and
the Iranians the person who tells the
best wrestling forever yeah who tells we
started the in tells the rest or it has
by the way this Lamba these these
Africans the Senegalese they've been
doing this thing for thousands of years
is a form of mixed martial arts
what are they doing the fight they got
stand up and then got ground fighting
you know as long as men have been around
together the best storytellers like one
of the things that make the grace is so
dynamic in such a you know pioneers is
they can tell a [ __ ] story man
yeah but wouldn't you also say that the
Gracie great marketing but when you say
that the graces are unique in that they
were the first at least to my
recollection the martial arts always was
sort of famed as small guy beats a big
guy but they were the first family I
feel in first technique where you could
really see how a small guy at 140 all by
deserving breakage I thought that was
that that was their whole point my
design that's who was built Helio Gracie
was was a tiny little man and that's
what I can Marlys that's why they put
him that's what the ecology always great
see they you know the other grace is
they said no no horse is gonna fight
because he's the little guy he doesn't
look intimidate right and hidden like
just Hickson wigs and look like a time
not well either serve Alton looks like a
God bring up young Hicks and Gracie but
I'm so gonna go hold up of course the
Hickson's in to look at him but boys
look like your normal skin by the way by
then [ __ ] Nixon I'd already beat
everybody up in the valley to Iraq so
everyone's like you beat up Zulu yeah I
mean remember she was such a yes now
keep going awesome look at him there
there you go now no pop up first pop up
groan I know they look so similar yeah
he's on that bottom picture there with
is dead Wow Wow Jesus - yeah super
Stacey do you know thrown well I don't
know him well he was he was almost gonna
come with us oh my god amazing guy and
by the way they're they're not they lit
like guys like this he walks the walk
man he lives it Crone yeah it's all my
philosophy of greatest building image of
his father
he's also Hickson these guys come the
warrior oh my god
i watch Kron and at metamoris he rolled
with a commie I think it was
Okami is that who it was the Japanese
guy really good
maybe I'm sure and and it was really
well to watch him cuz they locked hands
and Kron I never forgot this he closed
his eyes for a second he just like
things like he meditate like he went
into a space no there he [ __ ] closed
his eyes and went like it was like this
guy's about to go say he's another like
it's a whole other just a complete good
who his father's yeah I mean you ask
there's so much pressure because there's
a there's a you know there's a lot of
great C's out so he won't go through
them there's a lot of grace he's her a
bit of their fuck-ups and they can't
they can't deal with the pressure and
especially your dad's Hickson yeah but
Crone thrive I think and then you know
Crohn's Crohn's brother was what passed
away that's a very young age and I think
that it really affected their lives in a
way where they I think took on exiting
ya took on responsibility worked in
Japan Mme Janet everybody yeah
everybody's so he's fighting and he's
been fighting away for a few years now
it's funny to look at Nixon now because
I when I trained with him he was such a
young
it's amazing what time is a thief huh I
found it very moving I read I read an
account of him and I found it very
moving I was like you wanted to cry yeah
cuz he was talking about how some things
bring you to your knees and bring you at
rock bottom and there's nowhere else to
go
yeah no matter what you do you can't get
out of it and when he accepted that his
son had died and he didn't have a way
out of that grief yes really god those
boys he's Aggies the great I remember
him as a you know what those boys were
always in the in
in on the mats with us and especially
that one he was in choke he's in the
movie choke livin with it they would be
beautiful boy you know I mean listen I
have three sons I can't imagine oh my
god where do you I mean if you don't
have another kid you just kill yourself
you know I think that's why yeah hundred
percent I think that's a lot of times
like the and I don't wanna [ __ ] draw
on this topic at all but like the mass
shooting in Vegas like you know that
stuff always [ __ ] with me when there's
that negative thing but and I have a son
man I was in a for two days I know I was
just in this horrible slump I know
because I think of my son growing up and
then can he go to concerts how's this
gonna work
how about this laughter my bad I'm there
now my girls let's go to concert on
Sunday I'm know I know Comic Con in New
York on Friday I'm like can you worry
about it that's a place where people
dress up in furry [ __ ] costumes as
adults I mean I know every time I heard
that Kaka every time I heard the gun I
was like tragedy tragedy tragedy tragedy
tragedy tragedy and not just two people
who are dead about this yeah they're the
launchers when you get shot with a with
that type of a bullet yeah it causes
major baby damage but also people can
trample in this together do you hear
these stories of people breaking their
legs their arms their concussion so but
then I was watching articles last night
and there's you know it's the season
finale season three and this ticket and
I'm just like I don't you watch the
video on CNN it's Kiki Kiki I think you
know I I don't want to dwell on it
either because it could destroy you I
think no I think the off dogs realize
with freedom comes a cost always like
there's always gonna be soft targets
there's always gonna be a cost to
everything yeah but when it's that kind
of Anarchy when it's that kind of just
you can't answer for that kind of
insanity and what amazes me is how a guy
walks through the world up until 64
years old incredible and nobody kind of
says this guy's [ __ ] crazy
yeah right I read some stuff that he was
a little bit of a loner stand office
didn't really talk to his brothers even
though he had a business wasn't
Brotherhood they were just text but you
cannot like you were saying sometimes
you just can't explain the why sometimes
like brother was like what the [ __ ]
right no clues right right you really
don't let me die with two million
dollars in the
he's retired and he kept yeah I had
property excite it was good what are you
talking saddest girl he does 100 quid no
file granted these white male that's the
only thing really fit but you know as
far as mass shooters they're usually ye
yeah hey hey thanks for that travel ban
Trump that's gonna help like you got
these [ __ ] mats you know I mean you
got a 64 year old white guy by the way
by the way you don't wanna make it say
let's get off this let me tell you one
thing about traveling you realize how
many people hate Donald Trump bro
Wow right Wow and you're you do you feel
yourself like I could I almost get a
fellow I'm an Italian citizen I tell
them up I'm gonna tell you right live in
a merit you turn your back I'm with the
Senegalese guys who could literally eat
me for dinner that's how big they are
these are Muslims who are not these are
the people that you say are dangerous
you don't want them to come into our
country couldn't be more beautiful Obama
went to Senegal and said the world could
learn a lesson from the Senegalese Pina
yeah well I I grew up overseas my whole
life and all these countries especially
in the Middle East and that one thing
that I remember is the United States had
such a great reputation the u.s. always
had a reputation of a place that was
liberal that was was welcoming to
everyone and our strength was that we
were fair we were the breadbasket of the
world it was all this stuff we gave we
to the Soviet Union even though they
were our enemies and stuff like that and
I think that for a lot of reasons I mean
Trump I think is a symptom but for a lot
of reasons people feel unsafe throwing
paper towels again dude in Puerto Rico I
mean so it's almost a joke he's calm
it's it's like he it's it's literally
like he's riding big he's tone deaf you
know he took the pill he's like shooting
he's not he's not he's not he's not
tactful I guess and he's not diplomatic
he's just clumsy
I don't know but to try when you travel
around not like when I was in England
Manchester dub and like I thought they
like Oh america [ __ ] yeah what what
sitting there like oh my yeah I'm like
yeah yeah
no no I'm Brenda Natalie been here what
do you guys both leave my [ __ ]
country no I love the country yeah it's
the guy I'm not going anywhere
I always a matter that Mark Twain thing
at Loyola to my country always write to
my government only when it deserves it
right yeah you would you get sick at all
now did you get you didn't catch aids in
Africa I got AIDS but make sense
aids who helps you make all these
connections because they're not easy to
do so much in Brazil yeah it's not uh
you know we where my company Joe Kearney
and I have a company war party which
produces the show with Matador which is
a company that that produces unscripted
television docu-series like this and we
have a great guy john gross tell who
gets us in these places and believe it
or not whatever little fame I have in
the world of of
action movies is big for sure or
globally and so I have maybe a little
bit of a reputation of being authentic
yeah and and it gets me it gets me in
these doors you know you don't have to
like worry about going in there and like
breaking the ice like you have an
introduction that when you went go ahead
just what I do and every place that I go
I go an hour before the camera crew
right and I'll go and I'll train
whatever it is I went with would Muay
Thai or would like you know I did I did
a let way in Myanmar which is the art of
the nine limbs basically it's more Thai
with no gloves and head-butted so I went
in I trained for like three days before
we saw what as soon as I start training
then I'll spar a little bit and then
everybody's going ah
okay other guy he's not fully [ __ ] yeah
he's another guy he's you know and then
oxic yeah I'm grappling whatever it is
and that kind of you you know when
you're in a gym you only have to be
there for 15 years people watch you and
they go okay he's looking at this I jog
oh man it's like dogs
it's like dogs sniffing butts like a
suit you can smell a fraud you can I'm
saying like sniff your butt yeah he's
cool right you got good dude say exactly
how does one house one spar with head
how does one do that you do it you you
just you drop your head look when you
spar you you I'm doing lights measuring
I'm not talking about I'm sparring for a
fight right I'm getting in there and I'm
moving and I'm moving around I'm moving
around mixing it up yeah and so when you
lock up and you know it's a lot of this
boom boom you do it you do it light
enough so that yeah so that but it's
kind of fun man yeah it's fun yeah man I
mean and they're small right they're
pretty small but you guys might a little
taller than me but start a [ __ ]
monster now would you go out at night
like experience the nightlife and like
the food and all that like hanging up
every night every night and I don't I
don't I eat and honest on the street and
I eat like a local cool experience so
it's and because like in Brazil I every
night went to like little chicken joints
and every night we drank you know the
cold beer and it's but there is a
country if I was a country that I said
you're gonna live in what which out of
the countries you've been to what would
it be cereal
I could easily live in Brazil yeah
easily I could live in Mexico City
Mexico City heard great absolutely could
live there really go city gives you a
huge [ __ ] city huge city it's like you
know twelve million people it's very
similar to LA to spread out and believe
it or not I could live in Senegal really
on the beach you know really yeah man it
was there beautiful too like the women
everybody's that Gorge gorgeous yeah not
just all black people it's no it's it's
uh it's white snow mix it's a mix
because we're in Africa where's that at
it's down it's it's on the west side
lower low it's probably where Atlanta
would be yeah we get up its sticks out
yeah see the car that's where I was
because it's where the race was Paris to
do car yeah back out from each in let me
see this right yes see where it is oh no
it's a little lower I'm sorry minor
marts oh I got you I got you because the
right there so now because the north is
working R in some trouble correct oh
that's Rocco Algeria no not so much
that's right oh yeah let me tell you
what you run into trouble because I've
been all over the Congo yeah you don't
want to go you know
Goma now when when Charles Kony's Lower
Egypt Sudan some trouble yeah so that's
the Ivory Coast right there and you were
famous Paris in the car race yeah yeah
that's that's where it ended now then
you were good Frank there did they do
better than good did they tell you any
horror stories yeah you know what when
you come from a place where there's
extreme poverty and then extreme wealth
and really nothing in between and some
wrongs you can apply birria and Sierra
Leone were the worst
yes Sierra Leone is right right right
under there yeah so that was where there
was a diamond
well diamonds yeah blood diamonds it was
where before they sank oh and Charles
Taylor Charles Taylor said the photo
Sanko in Sierra Leone goes you just have
to make people so miserable that they
vote you in that they're terrified not
to yeah and they control all the
diamonds and all the amazing fun out
there
yeah you should go to hell it's not that
I mean I've traveled all over the world
so if Jeff Raqqah doesn't seem that far
but I'm gonna tell you something you
should go to everyone should go to
Africa Africa is an amazing do you guys
hear that here's a dropping a knowledge
for you do you guys know per capita who
has what country has the most college
diplomas the most degrees per capita
which country you know it's an aspirant
you want to know what you want out in
Africa and in the world where is it what
stops the Africans from about Africa we
shall pick out which one no it's I
believe it's Ethiopia no it's not and
that's fascinating because I'm talking
about in all the countries in the world
Nigeria according to Thaddeus Russell
has more per capita Google that before
you mention more more calm just just
these the most calls do they do go he's
put and they speak many languages yeah
yeah and how was the food in Africa
amazing really amazing here's the deal
you got the Portuguese those bastards
they came and they raided Senegal and
that's where a lot of the slave trade to
pressure to
sorry I don't know if college graduate
degrees well that's a degree yeah yeah
college guys you get a degree
go integral down we're listening more
English Yonkers in Nigeria than in
Australia or in okay range I'll just see
y'all to the right there Finland Finland
let's go to that yes go number one
Canada okay keep going maybe they're in
the United States per capita yeah we
know she's gotta be per capita yeah
Israel Israel Israel Zealand
nobody to go since I've been first
Appalachian yeah would either way I mean
to him well yeah I'm super suspect about
it but I flow into Goethe but well Jada
Brian likes to do this he speaks with
such a confidence and conviction that
you believe whatever he says no I've
died was told by a tease Russell who is
a historian so you said per capita it's
so funny I'm also an historian you are
you certainly are you let you walk the
walk as far as history is concerned so
now what now what you've done with this
get the movie I'm going I'm going to do
press I'm going to do a bunch of press
for wheelman and Conan in Today Show
stuff and then you have some go to
Israel and then I do a movie mean Andy
Garcia doing a movie he's great rano and
then I go and do another movie in
Cincinnati with James badge Dale and
Jamie Bell she does a really great movie
called Donnybrook based on a book oh
cool about fighting writing the other
books great and I play a guy named
chainsaw angus which is the baddest guy
in the whole great me yeah that's cool
what what is the how do you see our
business changing it's already changing
in a crazy way with Netflix but like
what's gonna happen to the average actor
in ten years and what's gonna happen to
the business what do you see changing
the biggest change I mean I don't I
think I think the business is expanding
as far as actors are concerned more in
that opportunity of course you know the
these these disrupted these disruptors
these Netflix are the one who now
about movie stars these people who can
open a MOOC right yeah doesn't matter
really nope it doesn't so that's unless
less and less less unless you know you
got a few guys hanging on to it the guys
who were big in the 90s into trying but
it's less and less about that it's
really it really is so it's becoming
more and more about the actual it's
about listen do you have you have
educated consumers you have people who
know what's good and know it's not good
make something good people will find it
you know and let's give them access to
it yeah or you do books you do movies
based on on comic books like Marvel you
know they can give forever are you doing
your are you still helping out with
Chris van Leuven Chris yeah he's got a
fight November 10th yes finally got a
goddamn fire the main card on TV CBS CBS
Sports yeah November 10th good friend
don't ask me who he's fighting I forgot
he wanted to fight horn but horn doesn't
want to fight anybody
he once wait for mini Pacquiao Yamini I
don't think that's gonna happen again
you don't think so no I do not think so
what was your take on the triple G I was
there oh you were there yeah I took my
son
you know it's sunny I think we spoke
about this no I never seen him boxing
when you're always that good I'm at wild
card yeah West yeah yeah when you watch
a fighter survive and then you watch
your fight on TV it's like watching two
different fights you might you it's it's
even in person hard to score fight and
if you're sitting there listen I have to
tell you in person
Canelo to me fought a really amazing
fight he was defensively amazing he did
lay back a little in the middle to grass
laughs you took rounds off but she does
but he he fought defensively he was
amazing amazing he put combinations
together but I mean three four five six
punch combinations we're triple G was
missing like eight nine punches in a row
triple G was always coming forward which
is what he does always the aggressor and
but you know what triple G's got the
four belts do you take those four belts
away from triple G cuz maybe Canelo
fought a smarter a defensive fight you
don't I mean it doesn't happen that way
you guys didn't win the fight yeah you
know
that first 118 110 round she's that
killed the whole thing that defect the
whole vibe up yep the whole fight she
she destroyed and even even you know
Austria hunters like Jesus Christ and
that's his boys I Caitlin if you're
gonna skip we page on the table don't
[ __ ] us like yeah yeah at least make it
a little 1/8 this is way to is come on
you know she's supposed to judge this
weekend's you'll see they took her off
yeah good she's been suspect they're
talking about getting her just totally
getting you know she trains that she's
like one of the people you had to see to
train as a judge she's like one of the
head teachers to train people to judge
there's a fall from grace yeah not good
she sucks
yeah good but it sounds like that
rematches next which I'm surprised it's
yeah what do you think about Roman
chenko and rigging down it's a great
[ __ ] fight I think lemon Schenkel
loses how to how dare you Frank how I
love the world riggan doubt it can move
moves like I've never seen like maybe
lights maybe more to however Oh however
wait when you see what he see him fight
he Ted something really same thing but
he can very can be very very
conservative too though riggan doubt
sometimes like his last fight has been
pushed you mean seen his tools really
messing with my went to watch his fight
to I was out great to see how fun is he
to watch he's there he's there he's
there he's there and then he's kind of
waiting for you to turn around like
that's how fast he gets there it's so
cool this and it's a great pleasure
phase a specialized and you think that
isn't is really now who's the bigger man
naturally organ down right now for big
and I was big big yeah so he's tinier
yeah a little hello Boston great place
right now man it boxing is in a great
place it really a long time some heavy
weights up there some heavy weight wind
damage you know and you know with uh I
was just out there with Deontay Wilder
and he's fighting that louis ortiz ortiz
tested positive but it sounds like and
they'll announce it today for sure that
the fights can be backed on even though
he test positive
Wilders like I'll still find them I
don't care I'm gonna fight them so well
it looks like they might figure
something out were the fight still where
does this go with with the drugs well I
mean whatever stops I don't listen stop
it I think you could test
really any heavyweight in the world I
think you know they get better I'm
better really I mean I know I'm not
saying all of them are doing a bit of
huge percentage it's like and what are
they doing and they do in tests I mean
what are they doing I mean these guys
aren't stacking Dianabol dad you can't
is so old-school right so what are they
doing they have I think they have
doctors that are always coming up with
different things in labs I mean there's
who is that one guy in the box and
culture though they're not really it's
not like that you talk these guys like
you're not at that level where you know
like yeah I know I see you know when you
go around those gyms it every I don't
see I turned those guys aren't good
they're not linking up with the best
doctor minds no but I can't see who's on
drugs I mean I tell you look at their
bodies yeah there's there's a level of
but it's part of professional sports as
you know I made this comparison
yesterday I'm I should you know peds and
professional sports the same as
professional sports and foam fingers
right-handed yeah if you see a foam
finger it's the same thing as seeing
again PD yeah you're right you bet your
ass you see a foam finger bet you see
these yeah every Sunday every Monday
night in football every fight night
Friday night Saturday so I promise you
someone that card has some illegal [ __ ]
run through their system someone a lot
of them I mean I was watching last night
I was watching you know HBO's got that
special this season it's with the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers
football life Oh hard knocks I love hard
enough it's great great series [ __ ]
great I don't know who makes it but it's
a great series yeah
you know I'm looking at these kids and
some of these guys are just there's no
way they have not taken drugs there's no
way you know I was watching last night
the 3430 on Tommy Morrison train with
his son no there you go Justin fortune
trains his son oh really
Justin fortune sparred which it was
Tommy Morrison sparring partner really
now trains his son in a heavyweight yeah
and I was watching Tommy Morrison this
show his body back in there I was like
why tough heart crazy
bring him up chin Tommy Morrison just
config beautiful blonde from Oklahoma it
was in Rocky but uh that roots is what
gave him his break but also
like you look at the Haida if heavy
weights back then with Evander Holyfield
Mike Tyson
you mean Evander Holyfield who trained
with Lee Haney Lennox Lewis yeah yeah
it's like Holyfield could have won
probably mr. Olympia back me the
greatest body of all time yeah look at
right there how is rollers from now
because he has AIDS he's dead we did
it's uh
scoot go back gen there's a picture of
him where his luscious locks scroll down
I'm sure they guy there's the Sun up
there how's his son doing at boxing uh I
mean go to I guess this one chin is that
him yeah sure is from boxing no but you
I was looking as body and I was like
Jesus quite an animal what a beautiful
looking man step with that [ __ ]
that's all it from Oklahoma Oklahoma God
is jump on Rocky five but it's just yeah
you know you go back you watch those
heavyweights back then it's like God
that way the air of Frick you got
himself tits a while faked it
you know why I'll tell you what's the
Wild West because these guys take
testosterone and testosterone based
drugs and they don't take estrogen we go
hammerhead I'll take inhibitors you have
to take they go hand in hand cuz your
testosterone goes if your body goes goes
oh let's Reese more Estrin cuz we know
so he got tits then you get Rudy and
yeah oh wow so he had to get implants
the guys fighting could definitely go
all 12 rounds on the left there yes hey
he's shredded shredded doesn't stretch
marks on his belly the guy looks like
he's awesome blocks on how though you're
joking are those implants yeah you got
implants very weird
it does look Lee just it's it now he
passed away from cancer a cancer AIDS
I think cancer from the AIDS yeah I know
what I'm never right though so it's
always bro science yeah he had a tough
time with uh with drugs I guess for a
while
heavenly all yeah one way but yeah you
look back then and just the the heyday
if they caught the Golden Age of
heavyweights heavyweights right now is
amazing but you look back then you look
at all their body it's like
although you could say things about
Anthony Joshua you could say the same
thing about Anthony Joshua I have
reached of Nate I mean I've never seen
anybody that big that proportion is the
best-looking man in sports ever by the
way just I'm just from a straight how
tall is he six five I think maybe taller
might be six six six five six six six
and a beautiful man yeah and Dante is
six seven six seven yeah six seven but
but Deonte you know he wanted to play
receiver basketball so it is like his
he's a super athlete yeah like you know
but anti Joshua's is like thick but not
like weird thick like proportionately
right he looks like a action figure when
you buy a report remember the first time
you saw Carl Weathers in Rocky I was
like yeah it's like what the [ __ ] what
did you I saw him at a coffee shop last
week
he's yes he is these shoes play pro
football yeah yes you know my great he
worked I work to them douche who's that
ground work so I wanted to give him I
met a guy I was in [ __ ] Bermuda I met
a guy from Trinidad who was working on
like boats like he was just and I and I
you know me well I did he see you I
looked at him and I went I just looked
at him and I went that is a he looked so
big and feet out and strong and he was
forty and I said what do you do and he
said excuse me I said you're so big and
strong
were you a professional he goes no man
I'm just from Trinidad my whole family
sometimes you you know sometimes people
just have a genetic makeup better and a
betaine you go to Senegal that's what
they look like people from that I would
imagine LeBron James would look pretty
spectacular regardless right I mean if
he lifted weights and ran you'd be like
your I just had my bloodwork done not
too long ago and the doctor said you
have no testosterone and I said well I
shouldn't have tests I suppose well me
I've been an athlete seriously did he
say you had load yeah like seven that
makes no sense
yeah I see said you're just doesn't know
how old are you he goes 52 he goes
you're just running on pure grit and
indiscipline that's what you're running
on I said but you show me a guy my age
who's got testosterone and
I feel like I have it you still get you
don't want to do you want to do
testosterone replacement cuz they say
the number one thing where guys start to
have depression and issues and energy in
its it's correlated 100% to the load
test on I can't wait till that happens
to me I can't wait I you I'm doing one
duty Artie Frank yeah oh yeah yeah I'll
do it if you do it I'll do it yeah I'm
doing it man do it could you have a
doctor let's go get [ __ ] cider he's a
sports doctor it's a sports enhancement
dude I'm gonna get so [ __ ] big and
imma start fighting oh no you know why
because I trained you well you know
obviously don't train like you you're a
professional athlete but I train hard I
train right more than I am and and not
anymore kinda trader whatever but I I
now recovery for me is is harder and
harder and also don't sleep up and don't
sleep wake up which is fine I don't I
think I have the gene where you don't
really need to see my rest but I don't
sleep a lot but he said when he said to
me let me tell you something because
I've never done drugs he said if I give
you what would be a minimum of test
average he said you'll call me in six
weeks and you'll say oh my god how did I
wait so long to do this your age you're
crazy now to do that doctor doctor I'm
all over this [ __ ] then yeah cuz I'm
starting and I said to him tell me about
ACH he goes nope you don't need a judge
like I would never I would never give
I'm a friend ACH as it is a tricky one
yeah testosterone though I would like if
you have any kind I need to get checked
I got checked out mine was it I mean
mine was lower but not you know not
nothing yeah you know what he did tell
me my HDL which is the good cholesterol
he said he's never in his career he's
been doing this 25 years seen anybody
whose HDL was as high as mine you have
good genetics though friend as we said
Jimmy the Italian thing you know you you
know hit the woman on the head and take
her and then kill them then even do it's
that's yeah yeah now you've got I don't
imagine I you have I would I can't
believe you have low testosterone
I never many my born I don't have low I
have no it's a big diff you tasty Artie
you're here is gonna run into your eye
Brown you're like me Bravo said I said
well don't you go bald if you take two
sessions no here's the deal
first of all you're never going bald his
head he goes if you have the propensity
for the or the gene for marrow pattern I
do it fine you take your tea I'm taking
propecia [ __ ] - no it doesn't
work
don't over follows that no don't say
that dudes I can't wait strain I can't
wait to get on - I'm gonna do you are
you should wonder it doc okay because I
feel good right now what if what I gotta
go to get it checked off to have your
blood checking though yeah I need it you
definitely any man any may say over
fifty they say it's not a diamond
especially right now I'm so hard they
say that 30 your testosterone starts to
drop
don't let alone if you played sports and
stuff I don't know dude my [ __ ] I
feel like [ __ ] we need a juice Chinna
we gotta choose chin the chair god we
need you that dick at their getting done
I want chillin thought trt you're right
I think I want chin on a Decca Lynch
straw who I want ginger Navarre huckett
yes right I want to take you to Gold's
Gym just hanging around for a little bit
somes in approach you so so so you you
get it with a doctor he brings your
levels up yeah and what did you shoot it
in your ass once a week I'll do that
[ __ ] you know I'm psyched dude [ __ ]
huge
I've already pumped right now I'm
already producing testosterone I worked
out this morning with your wife you
worked out much or did your wife think
that serious that's like I took with
Deanna's place so I I worked it with my
wife and your wife and I was in the
middle doing pranks and stuff and then
after that there's a place called Treo
which is right on close to where I live
there basically so you I strolled over
mom's I work with a couple moms a couple
one two moms and you're just out
wildcard West all the time no I was at
today I was training at fortune I
[ __ ] love Justin yeah yeah he's doing
well yeah all myself just had two babies
tell me so what's up yeah well he's the
bass a good boy how old is Justin he's
50 okay just had twins he had a boy a
girl a guy
guy I met here slice he was almost dead
he was almost dead because cancer but he
looks great now but he was in manis
corner in Australia he's always a man
he's made us conditioning cut for a
while he went away from me and man he
wasn't doing so well made in do that's
right
so he had a what kind of cancer he have
broken its broken he had like stage 4
throat cancer
they had to take his arm off to put it
on he's a I love he's one of my favorite
people Northey the toughest guy I know
maybe the toughest guy top to Lennox
he's five eight fault Lennox Lewis I
maybe 500 yeah maybe he's got a hand
like this one of the toughest guys I
know a week after he got out of the
hospital chemotherapy the whole thing I
mean can't talk nothing he's on the
treadmill you may eat the top top two
toughest people in the world I've ever
met yeah like Oh God
like you want me your foxhole oh there's
an honor he's macho let it grow like
real guy yeah he's the tough you know
what sit you in the corner make you face
the wall like he would
you're not last we're st. for last week
he's training me he's he's uh he's in
the ring with somebody he's got his
gloves on and and headgear in that and
think there's a big guy he's training
and so the guy wants to do a little
light work and and so Justin says to him
listen this is light work don't get
carried away with yourself right so the
guy smacks him Justin punches him right
well the right right cross hitch Justin
Justin boom laughter the but were to the
kick to the liver this guy's like six
four for a second he looked at Justin
and then he crumbled it to the mat back
down it came to anyway and Justin said
to him Oh mate I [ __ ] told you go
easy yeah yeah he saw he's just like
we're cut from a different cloth like
yeah he's such a guy's guy yeah I told
you when I was training with him before
I was gonna fight Lavar Johnson
we're hitting myth I'm training with him
like four times a week I was scared to
say anything he I'd like this horrible
cut on my foot he's like he good I like
mm-hmm
just cuz he's so goddamn tough he's done
then he goes so it's the game plan with
this guy he's just a big puncher there's
no grappling so probably she can take
him down
choke him out take him over and over and
then
not got laid off duty goes so you're
planning on doing that gay just do [ __ ]
well we I guess I won't be there right
that's all right all right all right
yeah he just like the toughest guy in
the way I did press in and Steve you
know and yeah they're great guys and
they go you and Grill oh man you a girl
I just feel like you has such man's men
such guys guys and it's so rare honorees
and I go I go I don't think I'm a guy's
guy I don't know who you've been hanging
around
I don't put myself in your category I
was like I don't think they really talk
about how macho I am what a guy's guy
look I'm just not I don't know where is
what I tell you when people were talking
about tough guys in Hollywood I'm like
right now and then yeah nice to know
Frank yeah and then you go and then you
go and travel around the world and with
guys who do it for a living and you know
like I said you see these guys sparring
with four ounce gloves and no headgear
and their fight their sparring as if
they're in a fight as if Dana White's
there's like hey we're gonna give you a
contract dude yeah sure it's like but
that's a way in there still that let's
like you know that shoot box that bright
lighting right they just never adapt
from that a lot of them still struggle
with arch isn't good
yeah but they they instill this kind of
toughness in them Jackson was like that
for a while you are genuine Denver was
like that for a while it's funny you say
toughest guys I spent the afternoon at
Brazilian top team I was there with them
for for a few hours and we're Nogueira
came from I'm talking no guy was
supposed to come down he didn't come
down but I was with you know Bustamante
knows guys legends legends man and bad
bad men I mean tough dudes yeah tough
yeah yeah just different you realize
like oh I'm not like them no you're
people any Brendan Paul I'm not like
Brendan you are you are I'm not them
yeah
I'm not your I'm telling you no you
don't want to be no I love you for it so
much I would get don't get it twisted
look at me in the face right now
[ __ ] you are and that will get
him what their will by the way by the
way yeah oh oh yeah you are and oh and
one more thing you beat those guys so
right
please be quiet no it's different I love
doing these different problems different
culture she has an R
heart and he has that sensibility but it
also killer an elite athletes
he also I've said he he fought the best
in the world yeah and people yeah but
it's just different a lot of those guy I
know you don't know how to describe it
just like something like like when I
meet Kron or fun round Hickson like I'm
just like I don't know like these guys
are like pure warriors right there it's
different because they're outliers in
the sense that these guys are born into
this cult but it's also all they care
about all those right when I'm like
let's talk about you know harder let's
talk about surfing or drag right food or
like let's go talk about the meat what
like why you didn't start Darce choke
Sanji's right that's true you didn't
like being around the fight like the the
mobs oh you didn't like that's not your
thing but you're your killer can't take
that you but you're a killer even like I
have friends that are we all do that are
in Special Forces or you know SEALs and
this and that and you know I it's
amazing to be around them because
they're the true warriors and fearless
and it's good to check that world yeah
but I don't live in them now yeah I shut
down in that way yeah me too
it's a different animal it like it and
it has nothing to do with Chuck Liddell
I love Chuck Liddell but like we're out
the comi store Brian I had sets and
Rogen's there and Russell Peters and
Chris D'Elia and then Chuck Liddell
comes in the back and then that's this
fight culture I'm out who run away I
went from any fight situation I'm out
and I just went in the back you mean
wrote and shut the [ __ ] with daliyah
time out I don't know dicks or so happy
in that environment like to watch you
now cuz you've been doing stand-up so
much killing
watch him [ __ ] killing dude he's
killing it and he's around like the
people he really wants to hear round
like write us some comics right well he
was around the other sprayed it on the
way there talk you know what else it is
it's yeah there's also no ego no ego
well there are but stiff it it's
different there's no like this odd piss
night on my show you know it's not it's
difficult almost like who came out with
the assaults also it's you are a guy who
could not be more confident with his
physical self right so when you're a guy
who's you know you don't walk through
the world
with any fear of no other men right no
you get a lot of these other guys that
are there doing comedy save for a
specific reason and a lot of them are
insecure and a lot of them are afraid
and and are afraid of being afraid and
you don't have that vibe that's not you
you you you no malice that's funny when
we were watching this cynical these guys
as big as they are I'll throw my boy in
there right now in a heartbeat right now
I'll show you in there you know but you
you've taken those guys and appends with
it now but you put me in their
environment I hit that long flight I got
the food's weird I got you I got Frank
telling what to do I'm all stressed out
my money honey and you know what I do I
go hey listen you got you pull up pull
the hole up put on that I slap a couple
times i cinch up your [ __ ] going into
chocolate african droplets to hang with
the tips out by Pierce you're both your
nipples and you go one either no yep and
then I [ __ ] slap you up a little bit
and I throw you out there and you do
just fine although some of those guys I
don't know about your own but the top
left you got some you got some big look
at the size they look if I get if I can
get guillotines oh they can't grab is
that a car grab you see there's some
dick grab my kid by the way by the way
stop your [ __ ] loins because
otherwise you're gonna look like a
peewee around those guys I feel like I
have an advantage though don't you Mir I
do well in the [ __ ] Department but
you're warned these guys these guys to
go over here that's a problem yeah
that's a problem I'm grabbing you got to
grab grab grab that Panther tail and go
to work aliens came down and that's the
first thing they saw they go thought
we're going back you look like you go up
go up to where those guys are standing
with it with it let me let me see ya the
way the back Junction in the ass juts
the [ __ ] out but but that's why when you
go when we go everyone's on peds well
then these guys aren't know that's our
[ __ ] I don't know any what they eat
out there full for fish and rice that's
two fish
yeah there's America that's the be
honest Americans bill sure that it's
called the Biafra crisscross sweat
west-african it's just fast which is a
beautiful man yeah they're that
beautiful matter beautiful endings a
rump roast on the man the left damn
right it's everywhere in Senegal they
were there like that and the women women
are beautiful too right
beautiful beauty yeah that's do they
like the white devil they like the white
devil really they're very tolerant
beautiful people you came back in this
what Frank said he goes he came back
from Senegal and it goes like this he
goes dude he goes I never want to hear
another off-color joke about black
people yeah anything I never want to
hear the n-word use I don't want to hear
it he goes I loved those people I love
them I mean and and by the way let's go
down there make some super yeah I mean
sparse physically far superior to
Europeans like it's amazing to me that
the port the little Portuguese with the
one eyebrow came down somehow to Senegal
but no well so so they they were doing
this that that area is got the fastest
strongest people oh my god you know what
they do though all these guys now a lot
of them are looking into coming to fight
and you have they wanted they want to
fight they want and like professionally
like yeah but do they make money doing
this up there no nothing how about this
so we follow these two guys lock dumare
and and motor low there they're like
Elvis Presley and Bruce Lee combined in
Senegal they're so famous so the night
where they're supposed to fight it's the
second time in the stadium that they
were gonna fight in 40,000 people
stadium right they fill it up the night
before is a soccer game there was a riot
it collapsed
God didn't people died [ __ ] so they
cancelled the fight so my crew is going
back October 29th to now shoot the fight
so we could finish that are you going to
district I can't because I'm working but
the crew will go and dance but I've seen
a little piece of this Netflix thing it
looks so good it is it's you guys got to
see this is good to call what's my world
so fight world's the first thing
wheel man wheel man comes out I've seen
them going twice won a few movies I've
seen where so much of it takes place in
a call of it 98 percent it's crazy and
your your rivet it could have been could
have been is going on hey a massive
failure but it wasn't it worked out we
oh man I gotta go so no you won't see
anything on yet will man when I get on
really go to Senegal make some well I
gotta get on ERT and then I'm gonna go
there's a guy who thinks you drive fast
you think faster that makes sense yeah
yeah it's a really good movie and I
don't personally I'm not crazy about
that [ __ ] poster and I'm not crazy
about drive fast think faster cuz it's
not about that and by the way it's a
suspenseful move what do you think of my
history I like it my hair I like your
hair it makes me feel bad about myself
let you know that which I will know well
I'll always be a little jealous of you
you're 52 and you're 50/50 there's if
there's one guy who looks better than I
do
it's it's it's so weird cuz there's no
middle ground it's like geeky don't go
up with your voice bro what do you do
don't do that you know listen man I
didn't come here to be if there's an ad
for TRT yeah this was before no no I
worked out today well um ah did calling
and full set of here yeah even though
right now you look a little tired
I just came from the gym I'm in my work
you didn't dress up huh
well at least you didn't do a church
ammos I did he did our podcast in shorts
hand round senior senior senior shorts
hand wraps no shirt for an hour and half
no shirt I had its doors
he said Fox Sports he showed up and I
was like oh ok it was great that was
like how great is he though yeah watch
them spar
love his son - I work out with a son his
son trains in uh at the I'm just had a
fight didn't II yeah he lost he's always
fun to watch yeah he's great he's
beautiful he's a trainer a boxing yeah
yeah yeah well he did he was a trainer I
bought some her for a little bit yeah I
don't know if he's still there no no
he's at wildcards Izzie yeah training I
miss Proxima yeah man what the [ __ ] you
I see your son still in there every now
and then does he yeah he's been boxed
like a like a main
that kid getting thick yeah he's a big
boy she just crushed the kids you guys
moving in your new house yeah love it I
love that house we can't afford it but I
love it
well that's why you guys keep coming out
with [ __ ] Wilma hey dude you're the
ghost warrior relax wolf for you I'm a
wolf damn it may be best for I'll be the
second interview with the vampires
bro what's your sure what's your awesome
shoe say on the side there my Gucci's
poem line are they Gucci's yeah would
you guys do some very good cuz I'm
nervous what he's got know what I did do
though might not my 9 year old Rio is
playing flag football with his school
he's on the team love it and uh it's the
first time one of my kids was on a sport
where they were cleats cuz my my kids
just never so I got me in him I took my
words to him and I went and I got the
cleat member when you've got your first
power football cleats and you're and he
wanted to Sox anyone he wants to
blueberry mouth guard and I got him the
gloves cuz he's a receiver who said you
know daddy the coach said I'm a threat
[Laughter]
but it was he's actually athletic my
keys they're so cool these down the way
better I had a black spot built cleats
they were called spot built pop pop up
spot this bubble I had McGregor's the
mold in McGregor remember those spot
bills but then then they came out
something like you could on East Bay you
could go through that the best cleats
every Bam Bam look like Sokka nice spot
big name is sign yes yes what look at
those pretty sweet though they were very
similar much you weigh out that is a
status that I heard she got the
inspiration from oh yeah look at it
screw ons did you have screw on Gina
yeah just ruins you're not allowed to do
those but you know I know yeah that now
they make them so light and yeah those
things way those are like boring [ __ ]
snow shoes
oh my god if you type in a freaking
letter c letter sort of the Giants
Beckham's yeah what's his name yeah I
think Beckham does hurt leather soles
those cleats Beckham junior cleats yeah
there you go
I mean we could his new stuff is crazy
the easiest that's what my son got right
there look
yeah man in yellow instead of pink
cleats a maker insane crazy right
jealous was careful frenemies will show
up with him he'll shared the cleats town
look at that yeah he does all spice you
allowed to wear those in the NFL oh yeah
they do cool that I mean GZ you know
they make easy cleats they do Jordan
cleats they do Jesus it's crazy what
they do now man all custom stuff ah
all I got to look forward to is
testosterone treatments me too dude if
you want right and I'll be open about it
I'm just not gonna be seen I'm doing it
already
yeah good man oh you already are package
is coming shoot it in your ass yeah [ __ ]
I'm afraid of need no I just right oh
yeah myself well I can help you pinch
your ass really yes should meet every
Monday and do it together
hey I'll be over in a second get on your
tummy you know the drill
he's here you have some curt of instant
you get time for nothing do you at a
time I might have to piss on my fat dick
real quick go for it this is part of
piss first yeah oh we're back I'm eating
the starburst where we off we were off
we're off yeah we're off so this I know
the first current event J shop said to
me last night just play no just so just
bringing up so like it says the title is
runners dingdong comes out of marathon
watch how long this dude runs with his
[ __ ] out
while the mounts are like oh oh you how
do you really see this this is brand new
do that dick come on
oh my god now the caption of brothers
members raped man this one's a little
gay game yeah so these guys broke into
someone's house it looks like it so the
guy in the middle is the one that did it
- yeah 47 year old white guy his last
name is actually white did all three
guys are probably gets robbed this guy
in the white gun milk goes again [ __ ]
know what he's 40 yes
47 they didn't they didn't light him on
fire they just no no so they didn't have
they didn't want to do do that but uh so
they tied up the guys one of the guys
that they tied up actually said like you
call him the f-word the bad gay word
yeah and then he
city was calling like you probably you
know did this stuff in prison that
triggered that guy to get a metal pipe
and rape him with the pipe oh yeah and
that they're [ __ ] crazy people in this
world they're from a gang called what
heartless felons well it's very weird
everything a ringleaders that'll gather
put sticks up people's butts
yep 47 year old guy who he could use a
little test not 47 they make games give
you some tests he's here it's not bad
though those are the guys some time
gonna do some [ __ ] I mean just so he was
why the purge should be an annual
holiday there you go let us get in see
Oh
so Dan Bilzerian I'm sure you saw him
like do that post on snapchat or
Instagram was like running and he said I
just saw someone get their head shot or
whatever I kept running a Medal of Honor
winner like blasted him online
why so this is what he where she run
away what are you supposed to do this is
what cuz this is why children shouldn't
classify heroes by their followers or
their photos damage their in this way
this is what kills me about people like
you always playing operator dress-up and
so on and so tough when the cameras are
on a woman just got shot in the head and
you're running away filming that's not
what operators do please stop trying to
be someone you're not
people are dying you're running away not
how do you ever save as an operator
though he's in the Visia steel he was
just not he didn't make it he said he
went through buds
you ate through went through bud strife
yeah not all the way through yeah
she was very open about it he broken
legs tried be a seal and also he yeah
but I think that when somebody's
machine-gunning you you run the [ __ ]
away well because you can't and some
guys ran towards it yeah one guy saved
20 P one black kid one black kid save
twenty people who got shot in the arm
yeah I want a badass young kid a young
kid that so I don't blame anybody for
anything in those situations I don't
know I agree but don't the only thing is
with this Medal of Honor who has
every right to you know call a guy out
who's not but you know if I'm in that
situation I can guarantee you guys you
will not see a post on Instagram
running away going holy [ __ ] man some
girl just got shot you [ __ ] head
never that's not my first yes I know
yeah I mean what is this Instagram the
idea was like yeah yeah I mean getting
getting how many hits can I get with
this you know so that's why he blasted
him online I get that I get he also if
anyone listen I have the right to blast
band with Tyrion but this guy guys I
don't need to get off those Aryan cuz
who cares about him but I was under the
impression Hugh Hefner died like last
year and then he died again now he's
[ __ ] he's killing it he they can't
he's dead he's dead buried next to
Marilyn Monroe but I thought he died
already
no sir he's been [ __ ] girls down from
this from kicking him down even before
he died
that guy had some wise man right yes he
lived a nice freshman I mean what a life
you might have had lived in many ways
the best life I mean maybe I'm being
around three crazy [ __ ] you but a
little closer also [ __ ] an old guy so
they're just a get get get get get and
you take all these dick pills to give it
up yes your exhaust Etta
what's better listen into three
beautiful young chicks go baby do or
[ __ ] 90
I think young girls around Quincy Jones
when he was 64 there was this beautiful
girl and she was hanging around I
thought she was interested in me and he
looks me goes man you're bringing in
reruns [ __ ] I already been there
I'm trying to work over here and you
bring this girl in she's channel 13
[ __ ] you bringing in reruns I
was like damn and then he goes he's told
me he's cerebral and he goes like this
he goes he goes I'm I said well like how
old is you guys 25 30 instructions so
Quincy Jones
worms [ __ ] I was like idea of
the coolest guy Walt Quincy Jones like
Fred Sanford Jones and when I judge
icons icon I love a teacher so it says
that she sexually assaulted a 11 year
old boy because she just wanted to make
him happy he had chronic depression can
be made about being sad all the time
so what you fiddle with as Willie that's
what she did be outside the clothes they
Ronal each other outside the clothes no
actual intercourse and so she sentenced
to five years five years well yeah my
babysitter when I was 12 did you yep how
old was the babysitter 17 hottest [ __ ]
though how'd it go down did you approach
her no damn she chose in my father's car
what she was driving you somewhere or
you know you're in the car [ __ ]
around
no it was in the driveway and we just
got that's what I think a double
standard is completely acceptable if
it's a girl if she's older and the guy's
young when I was that age I wanted a
[ __ ] all the woman so bad - I would
have never came around I mean about
treants I wore short okay okay Oh am i
right Kathy no you're right am I right
mr. Peters am i right Kathy I'm Restless
nothing five years five years I went to
the Mexican female prison in Mexico City
because they had a boxing program oh boy
women and I got to tell you I was afraid
it's really [ __ ] women no there was
some beautiful work oh yes seriously Wow
yes seriously Hobbs I mean you're in the
heart of Mexico you can see some of the
most beautiful women I'm remember I want
to go I want to go to Mexico City for
great things about my space and great
things I'd like to go to absolute
definite want to go to Africa now I will
sketch in yeah all right in Cleveland
rather why how's this okay so in Indiana
cop saw someone with a gun and a mask
and yet up shooting at them but these
guys are just filming a movie so the
video is right here did they have a
license the problem is they didn't tell
anyone
well business owners that they're
filming a movie okay wait of course you
check it out
so this is a body cam of the cop and
he's walking up two breweries I had that
guy walks out allowed to walk out what
cops shot this guy that was hit he shot
that first shot warning shot
[Music]
well someone take it out his no you
better get out here stayed side cops
have a hard job that's a hard that's a
hard a but also don't film a movie
let me tell something he discharged your
weapon now that's a whole other ball of
wax he's got to deal with really yep so
he shot it at the guy what happened she
must shot it was it was kind of I guess
it was a warning shot but in this
instance they actually said that
nobody's and nobody's in trouble because
they didn't warn anyone so I think I did
have a gun in his hand and I guess the
cops in the right area very very public
up under the same holy acceptable look
at his shop let me tell you something I
and everything I do somehow have a gun
in movies he can't see okay you don't if
I try to walk off the set people like
but stop don't move
don't take that gun don't shoot first
think if you're a cop and you see this
kid with the gun he goes no it's a movie
but you know that's right he's lucky is
white yep true that's a whole other
issue that's a nice show you're right
it's not the way they will sketch in mmm
speaking of guns there's a couple in
Houston that was shooting weapons
outside their car what's crazy is a
trash yeah that's why I thought it was
so intriguing
she's so my word fire away three why
what do you do
they're shooting houses watch they're
just discharging their weapons outside
of a car watch this watch this piece of
[ __ ] in houses in a residential she
shoot you'll hear oh my god wait
she's just shooting up at the sky what I
mean it's not even super high it's kind
of like an angle where it could hit
someone of course he could hit some
because it when boats go up they go down
she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and should go to
jail so what happened check her out
though this is crazy
did they arrest her they arrested both
of them but look at this girl I was
super surprised she do besides to make
horrible decisions and hot so hot well
let's like it could maybe be a guy I
call that I call that so hey did you saw
some lady boys throwing down how about
this is a famous [ __ ] fighter right
in Thailand and what she does is after
she pummels the [ __ ] out of you and
Beach she fights other men she kisses
you she so it's a [ __ ] fighting a
another male yeah you could pop it up in
Thailand really yeah what's her name
type in what [ __ ]
kisses opponents boy boy Thai fight yeah
in Thailand
kisses opponents in Thailand I think
it'll be in town workers yeah oh this is
that little crazy I'm big brown bear
town what did you predict with for the
fight I predicted this lady boys gonna
[ __ ] you up
mmm definitely or not probably not now
if you have to put your money on it
while we're looking who Kevin Lee is
fighting on time version which I'm
looking for such a tough fight it is
right tough fight for Kevin of course
very tough how about George st. Pierre
and Bisbing I'm just not interested in
Luke Rockhold was so like he's never
gonna win the fight I mean he was like
Luke Rockhold was that Bisbing og about
Jesus because he's never gonna come
close to what he's doing that cuz he
wants to get the fight just figures it
out you know I'm saying like he's doing
that cuz he wants that fight it's not
happening it ain't happenin no why does
George come out of retirement to fight
him bomani
because because the paydays guys are
getting now he can get a huge lump sum
of money can because the paydays higher
you know then what he's gotten better
man yeah I think you know bismi said
it's Brisbane said spread his last fight
which one is it more Thai the top why
are you boy dangerous
yeah dad that said okay that's him
that's the lady boy strong dude I did
all this wait that's a long time man
fight so he fought out of the gym that
we were at he died the right guy yeah in
my documentary she's cute I heard some
well I heard some of the lady boys a
trick you out there like it's tough to
tell yeah yeah oh yeah beautiful mr
because the men have such like little
features so it's hard to tell and
they're somewhat gorgeous look at this
wait watch so this kid in blue was at
the camp that I was at looks like stand
right there is it is it frowned upon to
[ __ ] the lady boys from my parents not
know not for your Italian parents in
their culture like is it like off yeah
there she kicks boy
wait oh oh [ __ ] oh look at that
that has to be embarrassing Gambino by
[ __ ] well I I rest I lost to a small
person in high school when I wrestled
you mean a door for an active oh oh oh
come on come on come on oh and then she
kiss you got the end watch boom ain't
gonna elbows bro how about a concussion
and a dicksuck F how about how about
watch even watch this elbow elbow good
blocking there with that look at him
he's unconscious on his feet yeah he's
he has a huge head yeah and he was my
old man apart before the fight oh really
yeah holy [ __ ] she's just throwing
elbows elbows oh man he is getting Tom
oh look look at the lorry look at look
at how she knows the dish they just
stand
oh he's all out of it that's it that's a
girl oh no you think I mean yes that
looks like a very athletic dude with a
sports bra on I'm sorry
well you there's some cells not a whole
lot of them yeah I love that I love that
Thailand's so crazy open he's done watch
watch oh it's over it's over
oh he's getting [ __ ] rocked this guy
needs to get out of there that's tough
that this lady is beating the brakes off
this Tobin it's over right
yeah you gotta protect your fighter
there come on I don't think they're
doing he's in a coma right now trying to
see if they wait long enough to see the
kiss there's a good body shots though Oh
Oh
leave wait kiss opponents I wonder why
this is opponents with elbows yeah why
don't they show the kiss oh here comes
okay that's a pretty jug kiss him on the
lips feel like that infuriate him but he
can't beat her up maybe in this
particular second place [ __ ] a sucker
anyway all right I kill the whole vibe
no I can see it's a chick John Hart that
guy like that actor I've always liked
yeah anything else Jim not much those
are good man cool thanks to you
thank you Frank preciate coming on there
know you're busy I'm really not have
nothing going on I'm just waiting for my
test let's go we talked about
testosterone I got to pick my kid up
from scar great there it is
and you gotta go-what me at 2:30 [ __ ]
this is the worst all right oh wait
maybe I can I don't think I'd get my kid
for a while all right perfect
hold on let's go
just as wifey you and I got it justa the
place is delicious what is it yeah you
buying the calamari there they have the
squid have you seen this is it grilled
because I don't need fried cuz I'm paleo
it's grilled it's grilled sir can I eat
better
can I eat when I'm on testosterone does
that affect the eyes it's gonna help you
burn more calories you can actually
cheat a little more I think I know well
right will it make me harder by the way
have you ever [ __ ] - then you don't need
it until you take it and you're like oh
that's a hard-on really yeah how does it
do if I take it let's say I took it this
morning
in my summary dating boner right now if
I touched your pants you'd have a raging
boner but not you don't you have to be
you have to be activated you should take
it I mean I wouldn't mind sure you
wouldn't either would I you just pop one
pill frankly let's just steal your dick
is all kinds of rock hard cuz I always
thought my dick was just sad because it
bends but that's the weight of the head
yeah just like the man who's got a big
old he's got a hunch honest me to my has
a hump like I guess it's hump day again
beautiful woman sitting here we love MJ
she knows that she's psycho she sure
dress on MJ as a babe and Jess MJ knows
exactly signed up she's not Eli's
gallons gonna talk about genetic error
she does your guys we had this
conversation on there and the face how
do you not how is there no sexual rights
a problem but I can't even look at her I
gotta look the other way we pretend
she's a [ __ ] a big old there yeah
yeah there's no yeah we talk one quick
second I don't know if this is done go
go ahead Rappaport is he crazy that guy
yeah he's gone hard on the old Trump and
then he went bad on on Connor I know and
then he went bad on
who's the quarterback for Patriots Oh
oh my god what rap is he's the ultimate
hype hype B's like he's he's just a guy
who didn't give you a hot take they pay
him to do that stuff like worldstar no
first barstool sports you know it's like
that's what rap does he's a voice and
he's a talking head and he goes hard in
the mail he's crazy
and he's New York throw and throws crazy
New York throw and throw wind but but
but rap is like that when the camera's
not on I've seen right on that he's like
borrowers that get the [ __ ] away from me
but he's is he's so vulnerable you
should have seen it at the Mayweather
McGregor fight I had to tell him to shut
up
after the fight he's doing that I'm like
well that's not it that's what the [ __ ]
up rap is literally around like people
who will kill you yes like shut the [ __ ]
up
he's going back I'm going crazy I'm just
everything like dude there's a time for
it I mean I've always loved him and he's
good friends with my buddy Jerry Dean
he's hilarity York and he's just
hysterical yes well he went off with Tom
Brady his one tune is what you know I'm
saying here I was just
there's no chill in that guy it's great
you gotta do still with him he's [ __ ] he
you know what he is though I love about
him is he sincere like he's easy a
[ __ ] sincere guy right you know he's
just four Chinese stars hey guys come
come see me I come see me guys in San
Jose improv on the 12th 13th and 14th of
October this month I'll be in Calgary oh
my god I was just there hey hey hey
great great crowds Calgary Yuk Yuk's San
Jose before that this month you come see
me I'll be rocking on guys come see me
at comic-con New York Friday night oh
yeah oh yeah I'll be in Chicago on
Tuesday of being Philadelphia Wednesday
and my
Thursday well yeah we're gonna I just I
just do what you do all right see me and
this is real I'll be in Tel Aviv week
after next
yeah he's living me up my god Krav Maga
yeah tell them from me
they've Krav Maga is basically an
amalgam of Muay Thai and a bunch of
other [ __ ]
I'll tell them from you Thanks I'm
jealousy you want to tell you I've
always wanted to go to Israel that's
pretty cool
Frank we love you man brother Frank just
to the fine kid with grill oh wow
yeah baby